landlords should be able to charge what
they see fit in terms of rent to protect
their property absolutely if you've got
something if you're selling a laptop who
chooses how much you sell that laptop
for you choose how much you sell the
laptop for if you overcharge and you say
I know it's only worth a grand but I
want two grand guess what's going to
happen no one's going to buy it it's the
same with properties if you've got a
property and the rent is worth a grand
and you go actually I'm going to put it
on for two guess what's going to happen
you're going to have an empty house
that's going to be two grand for this
moldy damp barely fit for purpose house
we have a massive shortage of houses and
every year we fail to build the amount
of houses and as a result of that
because there's a shortage of houses
there's way you know I know I'll put a
property on for rent I have 27
applications I get it housing is a right
you have a right to shelter you have a
right to Safe shelter if it's a right
who's going to pay for it if you're
saying I should just have a right to
live in a house everything should just
be free who's going to pay